fighting competition so not only going
to silence because
he wants to be a liberal radical he can
do whatever he wants but he shouldn't
have section 230 protection
but now he's going to align with these
powerful companies
not only to withhold information about
the election about hunter biden's laptop
now they want to shut you down i i mean
they want to shut us all down we won't
cancel us all we all got to be canceled
wipe us clean
yeah listen i want to be crystal clear
as again as an investor and parlor and
living this behind the scenes every
minute i haven't had a good night's
sleep in
in weeks maybe one day i i got six hours
or so
i'm on the phone with lawyers and people
at parlor all the time
i can't say enough so sean behind the
scenes it's 10 times worse
than you even how can it be worse you're
being attacked by
apple amazon and google three trillion
dollar companies
it is worse i don't think you understand
some of the list is not used
specifically but some of them
how really malicious and evil the left
is
um they have they want us wiped from the
faith their attitude is this sean
the beatings will continue until morale
improves you know
go on twitter we will we will harass you
on twitter
we will ban you from running ads on
twitter like i was we'll shadow ban your
accounts
and we'll ban the president united
states who 75 million people
voted for okay we'll go start a
competitor no no we'll wipe that clean
too
where in history is that everywhere
liberals never read history they don't
do that kind of thing
but where in history has ever trying to
push the beach ball
under the water and silence free speech
from people
ever worked ever and one more point on
this one let me ask you a question
yeah can on if i'm on parlor but i have
i haven't had control of
i don't even know my passwords to
anything i have no control over that i
don't even have an email account i have
nothing anymore i'm off the grid
but here's my question on parlor and
you're an investor by the way i will
i will gladly donate to a defense fund
in the name of free speech to help you
guys i mean that
gladly help you want nothing in return
and but on twitter they kicked the crap
out of all three of us
it never would dawn on me to ever say
ban that person now i assume on parlor
they probably there are people that beat
the crap out of you is that true or
false
it's sean i'm probably the most parody
to count on parliament
and i own a portion of the couple of
those champions forehead
i told you dan bongino's hair a lot we
don't kick them off
we a matter of fact we did this bounty
thing in the beginning where we offered
like
ten thousand dollars to some prominent
liberal with a following to come on over
in other words
our commitment to free speech is firm
and sean i don't recall you ever and
i've known you a long time
over 10 years ever saying twitter should
be d
platform home off the apple store and
now because we just
we we believe in this crazy idea like
free speech and open dialogue
liberals just don't feel the same way no
i i remember you told me i said well
what do you do if somebody's you know
virulently racist or anti-semitic you
have standards
and you know you may not get it the
second it's put up but
you have people monitoring it right yes
we're not a surveillance platform
because we're not a publisher
in other words a publisher like uh the
new york times you send your articles
they read it and they sanction it
somewhere we we're a platform
it takes time once you report it for us
to see it it's we're not a survivor
you'd never take down a new york times
article
even if you thought it was fake news
like and like you'd never stop
like a lot of people want to silence the
guy on with us here matt gates he's a
fire brand